don't let logic bully you what is logic
age age bullies people let me elaborate
it's a 52 year old uncle who thinks he
knows everything but he's broke his
report card is a straight F stop taking
that uncle's advice he got an F the only
advice you need to take from that uncle
is the following advice what mistakes
did you make to get you to where you're
at right now if you truly want to help
me out mr. uncle it's tell me about the
mistakes on why you're still broke live
in an apartment complex tell me the
mistakes don't bully my dreams I have
dreams and I want to give a shot to see
if I can go out there make my dreams
become a reality
you gave up you screwed up come your
mistakes I wanted to listen to you with
your mistakes but I don't want you to
bully my drinks if you want to bully my
troops I don't even want to hear it
I don't want to hear any of it so don't
let age or logic bully you